first and foremost thank you so much for
taking the time to talk with us before
the book reading Anne's first book was
called call me crazy this one is call me
Anne why did we title it call me in what
was she trying to convey this book
called me Anne it's an Ever So slight
twist
turn of the knife at all of those who
who who who did you know misinterpret
that first book and it's like okay
now now you're going to call me Anne
it's it's time for her to get the
respect that she always deserved why do
you feel like Ann was so misunderstood
because she did something incredibly
Brave at a time when nobody had the guts
to do it when she stood up for
gender-free love in the 90s
it hadn't been done it hadn't been done
and she she
did it in such a bold and big way
and took a big hit for it I will say
this she was never regretful of it if
she could go back and do it the exact
same way she would have she was somebody
who lived in such truth in such honesty
that she didn't she didn't have a choice
in the matter she would never
um she would never not choose honesty
and she talks a little bit about why in
this book you know she always said
nobody ever circled back to ask her why
why was Ellen you know the only woman
she's really ever been with and the
answer to that is in this book yeah
I mean without spoiling the book sales
can you tell me why why is it why is
Ellen the only woman well it has to do
with her upbringing and it has to do
with uh the fact that she was raised
um in a family where truth wasn't at the
Forefront
because you had such a close
relationship and you guys had this
podcast where you talked about so many
things
do you still do you still talk to Anne
gosh
um
look I said I said I said to her at one
point I think it was on a podcast
I said you know
if you died you'd you'd haunt the belief
out of me wouldn't you and she said well
you definitely feel me and um
I have to tell you you know it's
something that you know I'm I'm
spiritual enough but uh you know I'm not
I'm not
um
I don't channel that
but she has been so present and that she
helped me finish the books in ways that
I can't even explain she um she's been
with me so much in this last week she's
been with me in this interview she she
she you know she I I feel her energy and
and I know it sounds
um it sounds odd it sounds odd for me to
even say it but she is she is somebody
that you know like I said if any if ever
anybody was going to
um come back with energy it would be
Anne because she had so much energy
in this world that there's just no way
that it wouldn't translate to her
bringing it you know from the next this
might be a hard question to answer what
does it feel like what is the energy of
Anne feeling on the top of my head to
the bottom of my feet it's like a buzz
it's like it's just it's like it's like
chills it's like you just you just there
she is obviously Ann was a devoted Mom
how are the boys doing now they're great
Homer's 20 he's going to be 21 soon he's
more independent Atlas
um is somebody that you know I was close
to both the boys all through you know
the time the 13 years I knew Ann and
Addie is somebody that um you know I was
like a second mom to him even when Anne
was here so so now I'm I'm I'm right
there in his life and I get to pick him
up from school and I get to spend a ton
of time with him and um he's an
incredible kid they're both incredible
kids it's been really hard for them
um but uh they're they're they're doing
okay
do you see and in them not only like
physically but like emotionally do you
know what I mean like characteristically
do you see Anne in the boys when you
when you look at them absolutely I mean
and that's the most beautiful part is
that you know she lives on in those
beautiful boys and um yeah
[Music]